we're coming up on a new month which
means another batch of free games for
PlayStation Plus subscribers is on the
way if you're one of them and want to
know what you'll be playing in March
I've got you covered
first up ps4 players can jump into one
of the consoles best exclusives
blood-borne it's from the team behind
the Dark Souls series so expect the same
intense combat and brutal bosses but
with a dash of Victorian London and a
splash of Lovecraftian horror ps4 is
also getting Ratchet and Clank this is a
remaster of the original ps2 game but
with added moments from the animated
movie that released in 2016 so I guess
that makes it a game based on a movie
based on a game remastered yeah that
sounds right on the ps3 side you can
embark on another up rezzed adventure
with legend of K anniversary this is the
ps3 version of a ps2 game with the same
sword swinging cat you played with
originally there are plenty of levels to
beat and animals to me ps3 is also
getting mighty number 9 and if you
follow the game's original launch you
might think that free is a pretty fair
price
either way the Mega Man inspired
platformer will be yours to claim and
thanks to cross bind you can grab it for
ps4 too as for the Vita fans of
Bomberman might also like bombing
Buster's the arcade style game has you
blasting through 30 mazes across five
worlds with a bunch of power-ups to grab
along the way and yes there are bosses
to bomb your way through to finally
horror fans can sink into the dark
16-bit game Clare extended cut the
titular hero finds herself in a strange
world when visiting her sick mom and
it's up to you to help her find her way
back cross by is available here to
letting you play both this and bombing
Buster's on the ps4 as well and those
are your free PS plus games for March
they'll be available from Tuesday March
6 through April 2nd and one other thing
before I go Sony announced that starting
March 8 2019 ps3 and Vita games will no
longer be offered as part of PS Plus as
long as you're a subscriber you can
still play the games you've downloaded
or claimed in your library but no more
titles on those platforms will be
offered after that
time you can visit GameSpot to get all
the details
[Music]